at a Reception Center for fire evacuees
people wait to register for assistance
many are feeling the strain of being
abruptly forced to leave their homes as
the Flames closed in it's nerve-wracking
the feelings that you have emotionally
and physically are phenomenal trying to
sleep at night is just sometimes so
difficult
uh your whole world is up upside down
the poor hun is it's just you think the
worst it's just so difficult the blazes
in this area have destroyed about 200
structures but officials think they may
be closer to containing the fires I have
to say I really am beginning to feel
like we're turning the corner here on
this fire volunteer groups are pitching
in to provide food water diapers hot
meals and other necessities it's
unbelievable how many great people are
in this community just coming by people
that you don't even know they're just
showing up in Caravans of cars or trucks
or organizations dropping off Goods it's
incredible many people say they had
ample warning to prepare and flee so far
there are no reports of serious injuries
or deaths many people here are waiting
to find out whether their homes are
still standing others have just learned
that they've lost everything
this picture of a destroyed home was
taken by a firefighter Mariko Nagata saw
the ruins of her home from afar through
a pair of binoculars I could see that
the house was the garage is gone the
roof is caved in and everything around
is black so I couldn't see everything
but that but I won't be able to see
anything until they confirm it and allow
us to come up when it's safe so we're
waiting for we're waiting for
confirmation but I know it's not going
to be good news
she's focused on what's truly important
it's just material stuff so
um yeah that doesn't matter
nine-year-old evacue inessa kachanov
wants one thing above all I want to
sleep in my bed
in my comfortable bed going home a hope
that everyone here shares Rob Reynolds
Al Jazeera West Kelowna British Columbia
foreign